[Musique]
elle les vélos ont été rangés remplacé
par les platines de dimanche à lundi le
vélodrome nationale a vécu 14 heures de
concert cinq artistes et groupes se sont
succédé
trois heures de 7 pour un état dj
membres du blockhaus un collectif
promouvant la technique ça sorte que les
gens de voir dans les clubs déjà et puis
je trouve que
ça va dans la logique de
la démocratisation de la techno d'être
dans des lieux aussi imposant
emblématique pour paris important pour
dans l'air centrale un public venu de
toute la france montigny le bretonneux
bien sûr mais aussi coup dans caen lyon
paris ou encore marseille déjà pour
m'éclater avec mes potes taper du pied
et s'amuser comme on peut pour faire la
fête on a entendu il y avait une soirée
plutôt façon il y avait des bons cette
heure on est venu on adore la techno à
tous du coup on est venu pour vraiment
s'éclater toute la soirée je voulais
faire l'art en série qui aida gare saint
lazare
j'ai malheureusement pas pu la terre et
j'ai eu des retours de monstrueux qui
était officines et là j'ai vu là hors
série je me suis dit qu'il fallait
absolument que ça passe succès donc pour
ce deuxième rendez vous hors série après
la gare saint lazare en septembre
dernier près de 4000 personnes ont dansé
jusqu'au petit matin
[Musique]